[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen ihnen ein an einem bewegten
nachrichten tag auch im sport nadja eine
der deutschen fußballer chemnitz
gestorben uwe seeler eines unserer
themen von heute
aus russland kommt wieder gas doch nur
wenig minister harbeck spricht von
erpressung moskau weist die
verantwortung von sich
kurswechsel bei der ezb überraschend
deutlich erhöht sie den leitzins gut für
sparer aber die kredite werden teurer
und
trauer um uns uwe hamburgs vielleicht
berühmtester sohn uwe seeler stück mit
85 jahren
es hätte schlimmer kommen können aber es
gibt keinen grund erleichtert zu sein so
sind grob zusammengefasst die reaktionen
auf das wieder fließende gas russland
nutze seine macht um uns zu erpressen
sagt wirtschaftsminister habeck und
präsentiert neue pläne um die
energieversorgung zu sichern
nach zehn tagen lieferstopp floss ab 6
uhr früh wieder russisches gas durch
nord stream 1 nach lubmin pro stunde
guten 29 gigawattstunden meldete die
betreibergesellschaft das sind zwar
genauso viel wie direkt vor der
erwartung aber da hatte russland die
kapazität bereits um 60 prozent
gedrosselt britta spiekermann hat mir
heute im regierungsviertel eine mischung
aus erleichterung neuer sorge und wut
minister harbeck corona positiv reagiert
aus der quarantäne heraus per video
schalte in der tat nutzt russland seine
große gemacht eine zu große macht die
wie russland gegeben haben um europa und
deutschland zu erpressen und erweist
sich jeden tag als unsicherer kantonist
bei der energieversorgung in europa
ein grund zur entwarnung sagt auch der
chef der bundesnetzagentur
wir wissen nicht was die nächsten wochen
beginnt die aussagen von präsident putin
tiere hat verfolgt haben wir darauf
hingewiesen hat dass erneuten wechsel
vorstellen all das deutet auch
unsicherheit in die reaktion der
regierung auf diese unsicherheit ein
maßnahmenpaket ab dem ersten oktober
soll die braunkohle reserve aktiviert
werden vorgesehen ist auch öffentliche
einrichtungen und bürogebäude nur
teilweise zu beheizen auch home office
könnte es im herbst winter wieder
häufiger geben energiesparen hat höchste
priorität
wer im moment mit energie fast der
delitzscher quasi an der wirklichkeit
vorbei ist mag bestimmt ein paar
menschen leben die sagen dann spielt für
mich keine rolle aber so viele werden es
nicht sein die wirtschaft setzt in der
gaskrise bei weiter steigenden preisen
besonders auf eine andere fossile karte
wir müssen so schnell wie möglich und so
reibungslos wie möglich den prozess in
gang setzen dass wir umschalten da wo
das geht von gas auf öl also nicht so
viel darüber reden machen ziel der
regierung ist dass die gasspeicher zu
beginn der heizperiode fast voll sind um
bei einem totalausfall russischer
lieferungen für den winter gewappnet zu
sein aktuell liegt der speicherstand im
durchschnitt bei 65 prozent
holen wir unsere korrespondentinnen aus
moskau und berlin dazu zunächst lag und
alabama die wirtschaftsminister haben
hat nochmal klargemacht alle müssen
sparen unternehmen behörden und
verbraucher was konnte auf die
verbraucher zu der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher sollen dabei helfen energie
in wohnräumen zu sparen dafür plant habe
drei neuerungen zum einen sollen
mieterinnen und mieter von der pflicht
befreit werden ihre wohnräume auf eine
mindesttemperatur zu heizen so wie es in
manchen mietverträgen drinsteht wer
möchte kann also die heizung herunter
regeln ohne dafür vom vermieter bestraft
zu werden für vermieterinnen und
vermieter soll es die pflicht geben
heizungstechnik verkürzt gesagt zu
optimieren um dort energie zu sparen und
dann gibt es auch noch ein verbot auf
der liste nämlich wäre einen privatpool
hat soll den nicht mehr mit gas bach
dürfen das alles sind zum teilen sind
momentan noch pläne die müssen zum teil
per gesetz umgesetzt werden und sie
sollen dabei helfen den gasverbrauch
insgesamt zu reduzieren und die gas
füllstände in den gasspeichern zu
erhöhen und das ganze soll für die
nächsten beiden winter so ist becks plan
reichen um sich von russischem gas etwas
unabhängiger zu machen dass also die
deutschen reaktionen gehen wir weiter
nach moskau zu für begabt warum lässt
putin überhaupt noch gas nach
deutschland liefern
zum einen ist es so dass es hier
durchaus wirtschaftsexperten gibt die
sagen so ganz ohne die einnahmen aus dem
deutschen gasgeschäft da würde russland
nicht besonders gut über die runden
kommen auf dauer und zum anderen ist es
doch so wenn der gashahn jetzt zu
bleiben würde dann wäre das für
deutschland sicherlich schmerzhaft aber
es wäre eine situation ob sie sich das
land einstellen kann und der mit der das
lernen kann umzugehen in dem jetzt aber
ein bisschen gas fließt und der
präsident eben immer wieder andeutungen
macht was in zukunft alles schief gehen
könnte technische probleme oder höhere
gewalt zum beispiel verlässt er
deutschland in einer dauerhaften
unsicherheit und die lösung für diese
unsicherheit oder die verschärfung das
ist ein schlüssel den dann bloody mir
putin in der hand hält
danke nach moskau und berlin für bäcker
und chuck unterleib energy
russlands spiel mit dem gas damit
befasst sich auch zdf heute live um 19
uhr 30 zu sehen auf unseren social media
kanälen und in der zdf- heute- app
zweites großes thema heute die deutliche
zinserhöhung der europäischen
zentralbank damit reagieren die
währungshüter auf die immer höheren
preise die rekord inflation in europa
zum ersten mal seit elf jahren erhöht
die ezb den leitzins auf 0,5 prozent
seit der finanzkrise 2008 war fast
stetig weiter gesenkt worden seit märz
2016 lag er bei null was diese
zinserhöhung jetzt für verbraucher
bedeutet dazu gleich mehr zunächst
markus wolsiffer über die entscheidung
es ist ein großer schritt ezb-präsident
in magath verkündet die abkehr einer
jahrelangen politik des billigen geldes
die euro-währungshüter folgen damit
anderen zentralbanken weltweit wurden
die leitzinsen bereits deutlich erhöht
der ezb rat kam zu dem schluss dass es
angebracht ist einen größeren schritt
auf dem weg zur normalisierung der
leitzinsen zu machen als nach den
vergangenen sitzungen signalisiert die
entscheidung basiert auf einer neuen
einschätzung der aktuellen
inflationsrisiken
leitzinsen sind festgelegte zinssätze zu
denen sich geschäftsbanken bei
zentralbanken wie der ezb geld leihen
ein niedriger leitzins eine expansive
geldpolitik wirkt er wachstumsfördernd
weil kredite günstig werden doch häufig
steigen dann die preise mit der
zinswende gegen die hohe inflation für
einige experten war der schritt längst
überfällig
die europäische zentralbank hat die hohe
inflation im euroraum lange
heruntergespielt auch noch im herbst
letzten jahres als schon klar war dass
die inflation deutlich anziehen würde ja
und irgendwann hat sie kapituliert vor
der realität einer inflationsrate die
mittlerweile über acht prozent beträgt
aus sicht einiger experten können die
zinswende zudem nur der anfang sein es
brauche weitere schritte nach oben die
ezb hat das bereits in aussicht gestellt
damit hoch verschuldete staaten dabei
nicht zu sehr belastet werden haben die
währungshüter ein neues krisen programm
vorgestellt es soll helfen länder wie
das finanzschwache italien bei der
aufnahme neuer schulden zu unterstützen
wer da fragen wir noch mal nach bei
frank bethmann was hat es mit diesem
anti krisen programm auf sich sind die
sorgen um die hochverschuldeten länder
tatsächlich so groß ja das ist
zweifelsohne die ganz große
achillesferse diese unterschiedlich
hohen schuldenstände die eben einzelne
euro länder haben aber nicht nur dass
einige von ihnen die die höchsten
schulden armen bezahlen auch die
höchsten zinsen dafür abzulesen an den
renditen für zehnjährige staatsanleihen
während deutschland also derzeit knapp
1,3 prozent für aufgenommene schulden
zahlt müssen italien oder griechenland
für ihren schuldendienst bereits jetzt
deutlich tiefer in die staatskasse
greifen vor allem italien hohe schulden
und regierungskrise beunruhigt die
märkte wie die ezb gleichermaßen und
genau deswegen schaffen die
währungshüter nun dieses neue
kriseninstrument mit ihm soll die ezb an
ein einzelner euroländer kaufen können
wenn deren renditen zu schnell steigen
die zentralbank will also verhindern
dass die schere zu weit auseinander geht
setzt sich damit aber erneut dem vorwurf
aus staaten indirekt zu finanzieren was
sie nicht darf danke für diese
einschätzung franken war das von der
börse in frankfurt und wir wollen noch
mal genauer darauf schauen was die
zinserhöhung für die bürger bedeutet für
sparer ist sie eher positiv wer sich
dagegen ein haus oder eine eigene
wohnung zulegen will muss neue rechnen
lena sünder bruch
manch einer muss sich wohl vom traum der
eigenen vier wände verabschieden vor
allem junge menschen denn
immobilienkredite könnten durch die
höheren zinsen deutlich teurer werden
ein rechenbeispiel bei einem darlehen in
höhe von 400.000 euro einem zinssatz von
einem prozent und zwei prozent tilgung
mussten schuldner bislang 1000 euro pro
monat aufbringen bei einem zinssatz von
3 prozent sind es monatlich mehr als 600
euro mehr im spätsommer könnten sogar
bis zu vier prozent zinsen fällig werden
wer öfter mit dem konto ins minus
rutscht muss ebenfalls künftig mehr
zahlen denn auch die ohnehin schon hohen
dispo zinsen werden steigen
stattdessen werden klassische
geldanlagen wie tagesgeld oder
festgeldkonten wieder attraktiver bald
könnten 25 oder mehr prozent zinsen für
ein zweijähriges festgeld möglich sein
aber den wertverlust durch die hohe
inflation kann auch das nicht
ausgleichen
positiv für bankkunden bei rund einem
drittel der geldinstitute verschwinden
durch den höheren leitzins der ezb
automatisch die negativzinsen einige
banken sind die ihm zuvor gekommen und
haben sie schon ganz oder teilweise
gestrichen
jetzt zur krise in italien eben hatten
wir es schon davon die italiener sind an
diesem morgen mitten in einem
politischen chaos aufgewacht die
bisherigen regierungsparteien
auseinandergelaufen der
ministerpräsident zurückgetreten
neuwahlen stehen an und das in zeiten
des krieges und der inflation andreas
postel aus rom
nach seinem rücktritt kommt mario draghi
am abend erneut zum staatspräsidenten um
das dekret zur auflösung der
parlamentskammern gegen zu zeichnen
damit ist der weg frei für neuwahlen in
italien
die vorzeitige auflösung des parlaments
ist immer die letzte möglichkeit vor
allem dann wenn wie in dieser situation
italiens viele wichtige aufgaben im
interesse unseres landes zur
parlamentsentscheidung anstünden
einen anderen ausweg aus der
regierungskrise sah er nicht am morgen
in der grossen parlamentskammer in rom
viel applaus für den gescheiterten
premierminister 17 monate nach seinem
amtsantritt drückte der 74-jährige fast
ein wenig zu erleichtert bei dem verzehr
anzukündigen hatte
mario draghi hatte gestern im senat in
einer für den ehemaligen ezb-präsidenten
ungewöhnlich emotionalen rede um neues
vertrauen für seine regierung der
nationalen einheit geworben doch die
populisten der fünf sterne und die mitte
rechts parteien verweigerten die
gefolgschaft
man könnte es getrost einen akt
kollektive verantwortungslosigkeit
nennen was sich die populisten von fünf
sterne bewegung forza italia und der
rechtsgerichteten lega von matteo
salvini da geleistet haben als sie mario
draghi die gefolgschaft verweigerten es
ist völlig unverantwortlich denn mario
draghi ist ein mann der innerhalb kurzer
zeit gelungen ist der italien aus der
krise zu holen innerhalb von 70 tagen so
sieht es die verfassung vor wird es nun
vorgezogene neuwahlen geben darauf
drängen vor allem die postfaschistischen
fratelli d'italia die sich mit 20
prozentigen umfragewerten hoffnung auf
eine regierungsübernahme machen doch bis
zum wahltermin am 25 september bleibt
3ds regierung in italien
geschäftsführend im amt
in die ukraine internationale experten
haben dort massenhaft verstöße der
russischen truppen gegen das völkerrecht
dokumentiert das berichtet das
menschenrechtsbüro der organisation für
sicherheit und zusammenarbeit in europa
ein besonders gravierender fall der
dauerbeschuss des überfüllten theaters
in mario pohl dort hatten viele
flüchtlinge schutz gesucht auch die
ukrainische armee habe gegen das
völkerrecht verstoßen allerdings in
geringerem maße der bericht nennt hier
die misshandlung von russischen
gefangenen
eine meldung aus washington us präsident
biden ist mit dem corona virus infiziert
er habe sehr leichte symptome sei im
weißen haus isoliert und arbeite weiter
heißt es der 79 jährige wird mit dem
medikament pack slow food behandelt wenn
es früh gegeben wird kann es gerade bei
älteren patienten schwere
krankheitsverläufe verhindern
die steuereinnahmen von bund und ländern
sind im ersten halbjahr dieses jahres
kräftig gestiegen sie legten im
vergleich zum vorjahreszeitraum um 17,5
prozent zu auf knapp 408 milliarden euro
allerdings von einem niedrigen niveau
kommend weil wegen der pandemie im
letzten jahr wenig steuern flossen das
größte plus ergab sich jetzt bei der
umsatzsteuer auch wegen der hohen
inflation
wer in der katholischen kirche in
deutschland auf rasche reformen gehofft
hat wird enttäuscht sein der vatikan hat
den sogenannten synodalen weg das reform
forum von bischöfen und laien in die
schranken gewiesen
der habe nicht das recht kirche und
gläubige auf neue formen der leitung und
auf eine neue ausrichtung von lehre und
moral zu verpflichten themen des
synodalen weges sind unter anderem mehr
kirchliche ämter für frauen oder die
segnung gleichgeschlechtlicher paare
deutschland trauert um einen der ganz
großen des fußballs uwe seeler starb
heute mit 85 jahren in hamburg
unvergessen ist er als idol des hsv für
seine hamburger spielte er
jahrzehntelang wurde präsident
ehrenbürger und auch aus der
nationalmannschaft war seeler nicht
wegzudenken ein stürmer der akzente
setzte ein star der auf dem boden blieb
nur bei mancher ballannahme nicht
michael kreuz erinnert an eine legende
der hsv war sein leben seine liebe und
er war der liebling der massen
sein kämpferherz und seine fähigkeit tor
aus unmöglichen situationen zu erzielen
ließen uwe seeler zur fußball-legende
werden
unvergessen sein hinterkopf treffer 1970
bei der wm in mexiko gegen england
uwe seeler jahrgang 1936 zählte zur
generation der straßenfußballer der
klubs aus dem hamburger stadtteil
eppendorf musste 20 kilometer zum
training radeln vater erwin
hafenarbeiter und ebenfalls hsv spieler
war vorbild und
uwe seeler stil auf dem platz ein
sinnbild für das nachkriegsdeutschland
absoluter einsatzwille und im wahren
sinne bodenständigkeit führten zum
erfolg ein millionenschweres angebot aus
italien
1961 schlug zähler aus er hatte der
verlockung des geldes widerstanden und
wurde uns uwe nach dem sogenannten
wembley-tor im wm-finale 1966 gegen
england gratulierte seeler den siegern
fairness treu und redlichkeit tugenden
für die er das große
bundesverdienstkreuz erhielt
2016 feierte das idol seinen achtzigsten
geburtstag standesgemäß im ausverkauften
stadion beim spiel des hsv gegen
dortmund
in den letzten jahren hatte er mit
schweren gesundheitlichen problemen zu
kämpfen
seine frau ilka die große stütze jetzt
hinterlässt er eine große lücke
erste trauer bezeugungen gibt es auf dem
bronze abbild seines rechten fußes das
in hamburgs größten fußballspieler
erinnert an uns uwe
[Applaus]
wer noch mehr von uwe seeler sehen will
um 1 uhr nach dem heute-journal update
und natürlich auch in der mediathek gibt
es ein ausführliches
lebensbild und auch die deutschen
fußball frauen werden im 90 dass die
stadt ihm wird mit trauerflor gegen
österreich antreten im viertelfinalspiel
und es gibt eine schweigeminute vor
spielbeginn
ja und dann wird es spannend nach der
tollen deutschen gruppenphase mit drei
siegen in drei spielen ist ein erfolg
heute abend und damit der einzug ins
halbfinal eigentlich viel licht katja
strich so in london ganz schön viel
druck im deutschen kessel
der druck ist da aber im positiven sinne
die deutschen sind ganz klar die
favoriten und nehmen diese rolle auch
sehr gern an denn nach dieser vorrunde
da haben sie sehr sehr viel
selbstvertrauen getankt was die
aufstellung angeht wissen wir dass die
bundestrainerin martina voss-tecklenburg
wieder aus dem vollen schöpfen kann lena
oberdorf und felicitas rauch sind zurück
nach der gelb-sperre lina magull nach
der oberschenkelverletzung ja und im
sturm wird alexandra popp von beginn an
spielen das ist ja die frau die bislang
in jeder partie ein tor geschossen hat
und sollte doch noch ein edel joker
benötigt werden dann ist leer schüler
wieder zur stelle die top stürmerin hat
ihre chronische infektion gut
überstanden ist wieder fit
wahrscheinlich noch nicht für 90 minuten
aber vielleicht ja dann für die
entscheidenden anpfiff ihren brentford
um 21 uhr deutscher zeit deutschland
gegen österreich
danke karte stresow in london ja und dem
ersten viertelfinale gestern abend ein
mühsamer und auch glücklicher 2 1 sieg
der gastgeberinnen nach 0 1-rückstand
schoss georgia stand wie in der
verlängerung gegen die spanierin in der
96 minute das entscheidende tor danach
riesenjubel und
minutenlange gesänge der englischen fans
im breiten
das deutsche team hat bei der
leichtathletik-wm in den usa wieder
enttäuscht und wartet weiter auf die
erste medaille
auch kristin pudenz olympia-zweite im
diskuswerfen konnte die misere nicht
beenden
kristin pudenz zwei ungültige versuche
ein schwacher wurf nur rang elf kloten
vita kam immerhin auf platz fünf das
bisher beste deutsche wm ergebnis
shanice craft wurde neunter natürlich
hatten wir uns so im team bisschen mehr
erhofft aber ja gut jeder kann mal einen
schlechten tag erwischen wie auch gesa
felicitas krause die zweimalige
europameisterin wurde endlauf letzte
über 3000 meter hindernis
das ist definitiv frustrierend das ist
nicht mein anspruch und nicht das wofür
ich trainiere das gilt wohl auch für
constanze klosterhalfen die wm dritte
von 2009 10 entschied über 5000 meter
bereits im vorlauf aus
schon noch eine schlechte nachricht bei
der tour de france hat simon geschke
heute das bergtrikot an den
gesamtführenden die everswinkeler
verloren geht ja noch ein paar tage im
jahr
nach der hitzewelle haben sicher einige
sich nach regen gesehen der kam auch
gestern abend blitze und massives
wetterleuchten kündigten den
temperatursturz an wie hier im
tecklenburger land in
nordrhein-westfalen im ostalbkreis in
baden württemberg kam noch viel wind
dazu im schlepptau auch hier jede menge
reden nach letzten gewittern im osten
und etwas regen im norden gibt es morgen
sonne mit großen temperaturunterschieden
die details hat gleich katja horneffer
im heute journal gegen viertel nach elf
spricht christian sievers mit
wirtschaftsminister habeck und hier
übernimmt morgen jana pareigis
alles gute eben und auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend wie außergewöhnlich 40 grad
bei uns in deutschland sind zeigt diese
grafik seit beginn regelmäßiger
wetteraufzeichnungen seit 1880 gab es
erst zehn solcher tage und der letzte
war eben gestern ob da in diesem jahr
noch welche dazu kommen müssen wir
abwarten jetzt aktuell jedenfalls nicht
das liegt an dem tief caroline das hat
kräftige regenschauer und gewitter
mitgebracht und trennte heute
schwül-heiße 30 bis 33 grad im nordosten
von deutlich kühleren werten unter dem
tiefdruck zentrum mit 21 bis 24 grad
auch jetzt in der nacht regnet es im
nordwesten noch etwas weiter sonst ist
es häufig klar und die nachttemperaturen
werden wieder etwas erträglicher in der
uckermark sinken sie auf 18 grad bis auf
zwölf grad geht's am alpenrand runter
und morgen liegen die werte an der küste
bei 17 bis 21 sonst in norddeutschland
bei 23 bis 30 im süden bei 30 bis 34
grad und das zeigt sich dann auch bei
der bevölkerung in norddeutschland ist
es stärker bewölkt es gibt auch mal
regionen wo sie kaum die sonne sehen im
süden sieht das viel sonniger aus in der
nacht zu samstag und samstag über tag
ziehen schauer und gewitter über uns
hinweg der sonntag wird soll nicht der
montag heißt guten abend